welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor of Marsha in horn she
is the William K Landman jr. professor
of anthropology and international
affairs chair of the Council on Middle
East Studies at the Macmillan Center and
a specialist on Middle Eastern gender
and health issues professor in horn has
conducted research on the social impact
of infertility and assisted reproductive
technologies in Egypt Lebanon the United
Arab Emirates and Arab America over the
past twenty years she is considered to
be a pioneer in studying the role of
Technology in reproductive issues
especially in Muslim settings and that's
what we will be talking with her about
today
welcome professor in Hoorn thank you for
having me Marilyn how did you become
interested in Middle Eastern infertility
issues I am a medical anthropologist and
so I'm interested in culture and health
issues and I was particularly interested
in issues of stigma and social suffering
you know things illnesses and problems
that cause people to really have a hard
time socially in in their lives and I
was invited to Egypt to rural Egypt to
be part of a study of a blinding eye
disease and I I went there and I soon
became very clear to me that when you
asked women about whether or not they
had children that those who did not felt
a sort of shame and I thought
infertility must be a really hard
problem for Egyptian women and so indeed
I went back and I did a literature
review and I found that throughout the
Middle Eastern world women who were
unable to have children really suffered
social stigma ostracism and so on and it
became really the beginning it was
really the first time that a social
scientist had studied the problem of
infertility particularly for women
outside of the Western world I
understand you interviewed more than 500
Muslim
couples as a non-muslim American woman
it seems implausible that they would
share such personal and emotionally
painful information with you
how did you manage such a remarkable
feat well I've been working in the
Middle East since the mid-1980s and I
think that this is where being an area
studies scholars really important
learning the language the culture living
there immersing yourself in the country
and that's what anthropologists do we
tend to live for long periods of time so
I've lived in the Middle East for years
now both in Egypt Lebanon United Arab
Emirates and over the course of time
I've become very familiar with Muslim
the religion society and so forth and
with infertility for couples anywhere
it's usually such a painful personal
story that when you sit privately with
an infertile woman or a man or together
as a couple I think no matter where you
are often it's the first time that
anybody has really asked them to tell
their story and once people are feeling
confident that it's going to be private
and confidential it's often unbelievable
how there's a sort of outpouring of
emotion and people want to tell their
story about how they married and what
happened and all the treatments they've
gone through and that's really been my
experience especially working with
middle-eastern Muslim women
I hardly I think I've never met a woman
who didn't want to talk to me about her
infertility story lest I with men I
actually did a major study of male
infertility in 2003 and there was some
reluctance for men to talk to me alone
but even so I interviewed over 200 men
who were going through infertility
treatment with their wives and it was
quite remarkable the things that they
were willing to tell me okay in Egypt
you studied two poor urban women and
their attempts to become pregnant
through a variety of means as well as
wealthy couples using in vitro
technology tell us about some of your
findings yeah it's really an important
point to make that what you can do to
overcome your infertility is really
stratified by your class status and
society
the world now has a huge in vitro
fertilization industry and it's mostly a
private industry where physicians are
offering ivf testa to baby making in
private clinics private hospitals and so
if you're a poor couple and you don't
have the money to basically access a
cycle of IVF you're basically limited
from one of them the only effective
solutions for for many types of
infertility infertility is a difficult
problem to treat actually there really
aren't that many medicines that overcome
infertility especially for male
infertility and so often the only
solution especially for women who've got
blocked fallopian tubes as a result of
an infection the only solution for them
is to do in vitro fertilization it's
expensive in the United States the
average cost of one cycle of IVF is
about $10,000 in the Middle East it's
about 2,000 to 3,000 dollars to do one
cycle of IVF and for many poor couples
that's more than their annual salaries
so that is the tragedy of infertility
around the world for poor people so how
does infertility and its treatment work
within the boundaries of the Muslim
religion it's really interesting Islam
is a religion that very much encourages
science technology and medicine in fact
there are many sayings about God created
treatments so that people would use them
and seek them God created doctors so
that they could use their skills to heal
people it's a very proactive despite
many stereotypes about fatalism in the
Muslim religion it's actually a very
agentive activist kind of stance toward
doing things to overcome problems in
your life and so with infertility people
have the notion that you must search
you must quest my first book was called
quest for conception and people would
say I'm searching for children you know
this is a journey that we're on and so
people are very active about going to
doctors and seeking therapy and seeking
traditional therapies of all kinds the
religion has also been very permissive
toward in vitro fertilization saying
it's okay to
test-tube baby as long as you're using
sperm from the husband eggs from the
wife you're making an embryo outside and
putting the embryo back into the womb of
this the of the wife during the period
of marriage as long as you're doing that
it's considered very acceptable and this
is why there's no booming IVF industry
in the Middle East in the Muslim world
in general but there are some
restrictions in the dominant form of
Islam Sunni Islam there's basically a
ban on using third-party donors no sperm
donation no egg donation no embryo
donation and no surrogacy and so for
couples who need those kinds of
technologies this is where religion sort
of puts limits on your ability to go
forward okay
adoption springs to mind is that not an
option
yeah adoption is really not a viable
option for most people in the Muslim
countries Islam there's a great deal of
discussion in the Quran and in the
scriptures about being kind toward
orphans bringing them up well raising
orphans as a sort of permanent foster
parent the problem comes in trying to do
what we would know as legal adoption
where you take a child you basically
give it legal
you know parentage you use your surname
the inheritance goes to the child you're
raising the child as if it is your
biological child that is not allowed in
Islam there are limits on that and so
for most Muslim couples the immediate
reaction toward the question of adoption
as well it's against the religion so I
can't go there having said that there
are couples who eventually do foster
children permanently but it is not a
common solution and in fact around the
world in the West we always say oh
adoption that you're infertile oh go
adopt adoption is not an easy solution
even for affluent Western couples it's
become more difficult you know less
available children you have to go into
this transnational world of adoption
which can be very costly so adoption
isn't necessarily the you know obvious
solution for infertility many people
want you know to chase the blood tie
they want to have a biological child and
so often they'll go through many
attempts to try treatment before they'll
go for adoption okay you talked briefly
about male infertility and interviewing
more than 200 males tell us a little bit
about what you found there in terms of
your research you know male infertility
is the thing that right now fascinates
me I'm writing a book called
reconceiving middle eastern manhood
Islam assisted reproduction and modern
masculinities because the secret is that
around the world more than half of all
cases of infertility actually involve a
so-called male factor and male factor
infertility is the most difficult to
treat often you can't do anything about
it and there are parts of the world
where clearly the male infertility
problems are more severe I would argue
that in the Middle East there's some
serious problems of male infertility
probably due to heavy smoking
environmental contamination and also
probably some genetic issues that arise
and so there's a lot of male infertility
around the world and very little
discussion of it it's often very
emasculating for men to admit and often
in marriage when it's discovered that
it's the husband
that's infertile it becomes this big
secret deeply-held the woman is expected
to share that secret to carry the burden
of the infertility on her own shoulders
to cover for her husband and so women
often do this it's remarkable
you know the scholarship shows that
women are often the keeper of their
husband's secret it often makes marriage
actually nicer because often men are so
grateful that their wife will you know
be in a childless marriage with them
that often they're very loving marriages
and in fact one of my big findings from
the Middle East is this refutation of
the stereotype that somehow an infertile
marriage in a Muslim country immediately
goes into divorce or something awful not
so I have met so many hundreds of
long-term very stable very loving
marriages both where the husband isn't
fruit 'el and where the wife is
infertile and often these couples
because they are bound together by this
quest they become very connected to each
other very solidified in their union and
actually it seems to promote in medicine
some cases extremely
the marriage is where couples say you
know we're you know precious to each
other even if we never have children and
I've seen hundreds of marriages like
that so my book on middle-eastern
masculinity in some ways is a kind of
antidote or I'm trying to argue against
so many negative stereotypes that we
have of Arab men you know I've seen
hundreds of very loving wonderful Middle
Eastern men who are completely committed
to their marriages and their wives
that's very interesting how about your
latest research interest reproductive
tourism in the Middle East what is it
and why are you studying it you know
we're now beginning to talk about this
new phenomenon of medical tourism and in
my area reproductive tourism or
fertility tourism and it basically means
that people are seeking solutions for
their infertility particularly IVF and
other assisted reproductive technologies
by moving usually from one country to
another or one region to another because
generally there's some barrier to access
in their home country it could be a
religious barrier financial lack of you
know treatment legislation whatever and
so in the Middle East ever since I
started working on infertility I
realized that people were journeying
they were coming from remote regions of
Egypt they were going across national
borders they were going to Saudi Arabia
to get the the hormonal medications
necessary for the treatments there was a
lot of movement and mobility people
coming back to their home country from
labor migration because they trusted the
medical system in their home country
more and so I thought this is really
interesting people are moving across
borders seeking these technologies and
what became very interesting to me was
the sort of Islamic issue involved
because as I mentioned there is a ban
across the Sunni Muslim world in terms
of accessing donor egg donor embryo and
donor sperm in the very very late 1990s
the Grand Ayatollah of the country of
Iran Iran is a Shia dominant Islamic
Republic the grand leader of the Shia
religion in Islam decided that he would
approve
of third-party gamete donation that it
was okay to use donor egg donor sperm
and donor embryo and so now since the
new millennium since the year 2000 there
are now clinics in Iran and in Lebanon
which is a Shia dominant country that's
following the Iranian lead these two
countries Iran and Lebanon now offer
third party gamete donation and so not
surprisingly there are at least some
couples Sunni Muslim couples who know
that it's against their form of the
religion but nonetheless because they
want a child
they want to save their marriage they
want to have kids they're actually
traveling to Iran or to Lebanon in
search of usually donor egg less so
donors sperms so it's been really
interesting to look at the movement and
last year I spent half of the year in
the United Arab Emirates Dubai which is
the sort of global hub of all forms of
movement in the Middle East and I
interviewed couples coming to a big
infertility clinic I interviewed couples
from 50 different countries in the
Muslim world outside the Muslim world
they were traveling to Dubai hoping to
access the highest technology treatments
for infertility and it was really a
fascinating example of globalization and
reproductive tourism okay one final
question what is the most important
lesson you've learned through your
research I think the most important
lesson is that people are incredible and
have poignant stories and they have
similar desires off and no matter where
you go I think the desire for children
is a very important one for people
around the world and often it basically
shows that you know the humanity if you
will of men and women in places where we
often don't often see the humanity I
think for me as a Middle Eastern scholar
I see you know so many of the wonderful
attributes of people living in the in
Middle East and I've certainly seen it
through my research where people have
opened up to me they've invited me into
their homes they've been kind to me
they've shared their stories with me and
really in my writing I try to give
examples of the kinds of people I've met
very wonderful people with poignant
stories and desires that I think people
in the West can relate to and so in some
level I guess in my mission if you will
is to sort of share the humanity of the
Middle East to the Western world ok
great thank you so much for sharing some
of you are very fascinating research
with us today well thank you for your
excellent questions thank you
for more information about professor in
Hoorn and her fascinating research
please visit our website at Yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again next time for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you